so let's quickly review which properties
are indexed the name property is indexed
we're very likely going to want to
search for conferences by name the
description property is not indexed
we're not going to query for conferences
by description and it's actually fairly
typical that if a property is going to
have possibly a long text string as its
value that you're not going to index it
and city is indexed we're going to want
to query the conference's by City for
example which conference is taking place
in Tokyo which ones in San Francisco in
our case the start date is not going to
be indexed it's not that unlikely that
you might want to query conferences by
start date it's just that in our case
we're not going to do that and you could
have figured out which properties are
indexed by looking in the source code
for conference for example we see that
name is indexed description doesn't have
the at index annotation so it's not
indexed and so on for the rest of the
fields but an easier way to check once
you've actually created some conferences
is just to look in the datastore viewer
the datastore viewer shows you which
properties are not indexed by this
little unindexed annotation you've
probably already seen this and that just
means that the property is not going to
be indexed you don't have to be Sherlock
Holmes to figure out that the converse
is true if you don't see the at index
mark here then the property is going to
be indexed so here we can tell that max
attendees is going to be indexed now
that we've got some conferences we can
go ahead and learn how to query on them
and Magnus is going to talk to you about
the different types of queries and then
I'll talk you through how to write the
code to write the queries see you in a
minute